TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's the morning
of day two at Google I/O 2017.
Hi, I'm Timothy Jordan.
I'm your friendly developer
advocate on the ground
here at Shoreline, and
I'm going to be taking you
around all the sandbox areas,
just like I was yesterday
so that you can have
some of the experiences
as if you were here with me.
So let's go play around in
the accessibility tent, which
is, of course, all about
giving all of your users
a great experience
with your service.
Let's check it out.
Hi, Rob, how you doing?
ROB: Good, how are you?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm doing great.
So can you help me with the
accessibility of my website?
ROB: Absolutely.
So what we're showing
here is the new Audits 2.0
panel in DevTools.
So Audits 2.0 is basically
taking the very popular
Lighthouse Chrome extension
and integrating it directly
into DevTools.
So this will run
a number of checks
on your site for various web
app stuff, performance, best
practices, and,
especially, accessibility.
So--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right, well,
let's see what's wrong with it.
ROB: So here we've
got a page that
has some form elements,
which are missing
their associated labels.
And so if you want, you
can actually go and, like,
click on these nodes right here,
and that will actually take you
into the elements panel.
So here we're showing the new
accessibility tab as well.
So you can inspect all
sorts of information
about this node, this little
input field right here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
ROB: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: But
it looks like it's not
going to read anything.
ROB: Right.
So right now, we don't have
a label for this control,
so a screen reader is not
going to know what to announce.
So we actually do have a
label element right down here.
If you want, you can
Control click on that.
Yep, and add an attribute.
You can type in 4
equals sub dash name.
Yep.
Hit Enter, and
what that does, now
if you click on this
input field again.
There you go.
Now you can see that
you've associated
the label with the control.
It's got a nice name
and a screen reader
will announce it and
tell the user what
they're about to interact with.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome!
ROB: Yeah!
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That was easy, Rob.
Thanks!
ROB: Absolutely.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
Well, we're going to go
look at some more stuff.
ROB: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Thank you so much.
ROB: Absolutely.
Happy to help.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right, let's
go check out this selfie stick
with my friend, Austin.
How you doing, Austin?
AUSTIN: Good.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So you've
got a selfie stick, which
is designed for people
that selfie sticks usually
aren't well designed for.
AUSTIN: Exactly, yeah.
So we have a pixel
here running TalkBack,
which is a native
screen unit to Android,
and we have a feature
that will give feedback
when it's in the camera mode
to what's on the screen.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let
me see what it says.
SELFIE VOICE: Camera two faces.
Shutter button two faces.
Double tap to activate.
Two-- Shutter Button
is now enabled.
Photo taken.
Two faces.
AUSTIN: Yeah, it
just took a selfie.
So it's giving audible
feedback to what's
on the screen, if
the face is centered,
and if it's good for selfie.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right,
there's one more thing
that I want to check out.
It's really cool, and
it's right over here.
Hi, Jessica.
So this is a spoon
for people who have,
say, limited hand movement.
Right?
And I'm just going to
go and try and use it,
if that's all right.
[CHUCKLES]
The trick is to try
and dump the beans out.
I can't do it.
That's really cool!
Thank you so much.
I'll put that down.
[MUSIC PLAYING]